في اقليم يدوم بس اوكرانيا قالت قياده
الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها صدر ثماني
محاولات تقدم من روسيا وصفاتها الكبيره
وشمال المدينه الى ان الاوضاع تحت السيطره
وفي
جنوب استهدف مدن وبلدات على طول خط
المواجهه في المقاطعه خلال ساعه الاخيره
وانضم الينا من خير سنه مراسلنا تامر اسمر
مرحبا بك تامر واذا كان بالامكان ان
تطلعنا على اخر التطورات الميداليه
ام عثمان بالفعل القصف الروسي يتكثف
يتواصل على مقاطع
وهذا القصف وفقا للقوات الاوكرانيه يا
طالب بشكل اساسي البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
بالاضافه الى
المناطق الماهوله بالسكان والحديث وفقا
لهيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه خلال الساعات
الماضيه عن قتلى وجرحى في صفوف المدنيه
قبل قليل ونحن ننتظر هذا الهواء تحدثت
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه
زبوجيا وتحدثت عن اكثر من 150 هجوما
بالمدفعيه الثقيله نفذتها القوات الروسيه
على المناطق السكنيه ومناطق البنيه
التحتيه وتحدثت عن اكثر من 30 بلاغا يفيد
بتدمير منازل والحديث ايضا المهم قد يكون
خلال الدقائق الاخيره هو نقلا عن المتحدث
باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه التي
قالت بان القوات الاوكرانيه تمكنت بالفعل
من تحيد اخر منطقه لتواجد القوات الروسيه
في المناطق الساحليه بمقاطعه ميكو لايف
وهي بالقرب من منطقه اوتشاكوف وكاستروب
تمكنت من تحيدها كانت موقعا لتمركز القوات
الروسيه الان هذه
واتحدث اليك واستمع ايضا الى الى صوت
الانفجار في هذه اللحظه صوت القصف هذه هي
المنطقه التي تتحدث عنها تشير اليها
المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب
باتت الان منطقه رماديه على حد وصفها
بمعنى انها لم تعد في قبضه القوات الروسيه
ولم تعد حتى هذه اللحظه بقبضه القوات
الاوكرانيه تطورات المتسارعه المتلاحقه
ايضا في زبرجيا في زبروجه تقول قوات
الاوكرانيه هناك وتحديدا همم عمده
الاوكراني بان القوات الاوكرانيات تواصل
قصف خطوط الامداد والجسور التي يعني تصل
من خلالها التعزيزات العسكريه الروسيه الى
القوات المرابطه في الريف ز جاء الجنوبي
والحديث تحديدا عن شبه جزيره القرم التي
باتت بالفعل خط امداد وفقا للقوات
الاوكرانيه الى الجانب الروسي المتمركز في
ريف زباروجا الجنوبي والحديث بشكل اساسي
عن ميليتوبل وتوكماك وايضا التطورات
متلاحقه متسارعه على الضفه الشرقيه من نهر
دنيبر خلال الساعات الماضيه تحدثت القوات
الاوكرانيه عن تدمير اكثر من خمسه زوارق
للقوات الروسيه كانت تعمل وفقا للروايه
الاوكرانيه على نقل العتاد
الجنود الى مناطق تمركز القوات الروسيه
وبالفعل بثه القوات الاوكرانيه جانبا من
قصف تلك الزوارق وقالت بان القصف يجري
بطائرات من دون طيار وتحدثت ايضا في
المقابل عن مزيد من التعزيزات التي تصل
تباعا الى الضفه الشرقيه من نهر دنيبر في
خيرسون عبر شبه جزيره القرم وتحدث ايضا
قررت ذات الروايه التي قررتها او تحدثت
عنها في جبل وقالت بانها واصل ضرب خطوط
الامداد من شبه جزيره القرم الى المناطق
التي مازالت تحت قبضه القوات الروسيه في
خيرسون هي تتحدث عن خسائر كبيره في
الارواح والعتاد على الضفه الشرقيه من
النهر وتقول بان مدن تسيطر عليها القوات
الروسيه في خيرسون او ما تبقى من مواقعهم
كنوفا كخوف كهذه المستشفيات مليئه بالروس
ولذلك همم
ترسل روسيا مزيد من التعزيزات
ايضا تنضم الينا همم
الاخيره مثلما يقوله او الجانب الروسي
همم
التطورات يعني متفاعله بشكل كبير في
منطقتين رئيسيه في مقاطعه دانيسك وهما اا
منطقه مدينه اوبلدارو وايضا التطورات
الوضع في مدينه باخمود نحن تحدثنا خلال
اليومين الماضيين عن توجه القوات المسلحه
الروسيه اا الى احكام تطويق مدينه باخبط
حيث تتمركز القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
وقبل قليل كانت هناك معطيات رسميه اكدت
الانباء التي تحدثت عنها العديد من
المصادر العسكريه السابقه عن احكام هذا
التطبيق وهناك معطيات تتحدث عن ان معارك
عنيفه دانيه همم تجري حاليا في المناطق
همم الشرقيه والجنوبيه في داخل مدينه
باخبط القوات المسلحه الروسيه وصلت الى
مواقع همم القوات الاوكرانيه المواقع التي
تتحسن فيها القوات الاوكرانيه في القطاع
الخاص بالاضافه الى المناطق العسكريه
وحاليا هناك معارك داميه تدور بين الطرفين
في هذه المناطق همم فضلا عن ذلك تتوسع
العمليات العسكريه الروسيه في المناطق
التي تقع شماليه مدينه باخمط بعد السيطره
على بوقاداتنا هناك همم تاكيد على ان
القوات المسلحه الروسيه والتي تقودها قوات
فاكتور من الدرجه الاولى في هذه المنطقه
همم تتجه الى المناطق الشماليه حاليا هناك
معارك تدور همم باتجاه من طاقتين فراس
كفيف وكراس نيره وهما منطقه ثاني تتميزاني
بانهما تقعان على مرتفعات وهي مناطق همم
يعني مهمه على الصعيد الاستراتيجي العسكري
تسعى قوات بادنر للسيطره عليها وايضا
جنوبيه بمدينه
بالاتجاه الى
اوجليدار تم الاعلان همم رسميا عن ان
القوات المسلحه الروسيه بعد
تطويق هذه المدينه همم يعني لا يمكن
التاكيد على ان التطبيق تم بشكل كامل
ولكنها مطوقه من عده اتجاهات فضلا عن ذلك
تم قطع امدادات القوات المسلحه والسيطره
على الطريق السريع في الواصل هذه المدينه
ببقيه المناطق وحاليا القوات المسلحه
الروسيه بيحاسب المعطيات الصادره هنا
توغلت الى داخل المدينه يدور عن اختراق
خطوط الدفاع فيها على مسافه النحو اربع
كيلومترات في بعض الاماكن دخلت القوات
المسلحه الروسيه وفقا لهذه المعطيات لعمق
المدينه على مسافه كيلو متر بشكل عام
القصف الاوكراني همم
للاحياء السكنيه سواء في مقاطعه
مستمر همم كان هناك قصف اوكراني لسه
استهدف همم
هذا القصف اودى بحياه ثلاثه مدنيين
بالاضافه الى اصابه عدد اخر بجروح وهل
هناك معطيات تتحدث عن سقوط صاروخ اوكراني
من طراز هايمر في منطقتي
بالقرب من دير ما تسبب به مقتل لراهب في
هذا الدير وسيله شكرا جزيلا لك رانيا
مدريدي مراسلاتنا من دنياك